[Musique]
quel genre de fille s'oublie la fête des
mères qui auraient pu m'acheter des
salles de bains ou autre chose c'est
quand même pas difficile garde pour la
fête des mères je dirais pas juste pas
aux bougies sauf qu'à ce stade on n'est
même plus leur mère on est devenu des
connaissances c'est la meilleure
description de ces chats même toi tu
fais ce que tu veux qu'on fasse aller à
manhattan et débarquer chez eux comme
des furies non il faut qu'ils prennent
leur indépendance et de la bla bla bla
bla bla mais sauf que c'est la fête des
mères
[Musique]
en vacances
pour bien accomplir une mission on va
recréer des liens avec nos fils autres
de force s'il le faut l'amour d'une mère
criant à non c'est vrai ça alors maman
bon tu ne m'a pas appelé le jour de la
fête des matchs d envoyer un texto et
moi je t'ai mis au monde et ils peuvent
supporter nous accueillir chez eux
pendant quelques jours où l'état
viennent chez nous pendant 18 ans on se
croirait dans la caverne de gollum maman
est en train de cuisiner nous retrouver
après le travail j'ai une soirée ce soir
les mamans sont invités non je veux dire
non on a new york
on sort en boîte suis jamais allé en
boîte même quand j'avais l'âge de le
faire qui nous laisserait entrer en plus
mais je pensais pas que je vous trouvez
là dedans et regarde tu as vu ça c'est
quoi ce mouvement touareg
tu sais qui tu es son bras à mon tour
j'ai trouvé qui je suis sans toi
[Musique]
tv planquer ses pare-chocs
cette belle chose meurtrier s'établit à
toi et c'est pas moi qui vais tout dire
ce que tu dois faire
depuis quand aujourd'hui
m'a appris que dans chaque histoire il
ya toujours une page de plus
pour écrire une nouvelle fin
ce sera toujours ma mère
merci maman
et je vous jure ça fait trop longtemps
que je me suis pas fais et j'allais dire
une pizza
[Musique]